telling you it's totally legal these
doctors
they'll prescribe medical marijuana to
anyone man what do i tell them i need it
for
it doesn't matter they want to give you
prescription that's how they get paid
just make something up hey mr washington
welcome
hey doctor i'm gonna ask you a couple
questions and then
what eight
eight a as in uh then i got it
need lots of weed to get rid of it
okay okay aids um wow
all right uh are you are you sure you're
not suffering from anything else like
you know back pain nope anxiety
cool as a cucumber how about insomnia
sleep like a baby
with aids okay mr watching let's just
slow your roll for a second here
if you had aids then i would have to
verify it by seeing test results whereas
if you have back pain or anxiety
or anything else that i can't test for
then i can give you this prescription
for cannabis
right now oh i understand oh yeah i see
i get it
i have my bag okay so leprosy
no no because i if you had leprosy i'd
have to quarantine you
what do you no okay i see your fingers
falling off
no don't do that though that's not gonna
work scurvy nope ricketts
what no consumption no mr washington
something from this century
schizophrenia no you don't have
schizophrenia
just you know keep it simple please
what the hell is that i don't know what
that is a fish hook in my lip
just pick something off this list i
can't reach it why not
paralyzed does your face hurt mr
washington
yeah then this should help
you